اسمك انت حاس طيب منين جيت انت جيت منش من
فوشان وش تتبرع فلسطين نعم
ايقش تتب بزوج مل يعطيك الصحه ش كنت مش
تعمل بهم انت ز مل مش نمشي بيهم نعمل بيه
عمره وش نعطيهم الفلسطين نعطيهم الفلسطين
معناها بجلت فلسطين على العمر بجل فلسطين
على العمر شاء الله يباركلك يا بابا وان
شاء الله في ميزان حسنات ان شاء الله يرحم
والد وان شاء الله تتحرر فلسطين ان شاء
الله ان شاء الله ان شاء الله يجعل
المدونه ان شاء الله بباب ان شاء الله
يتحلوا على فلسطين وياخذوا الاستقلال
متاعهم ان شاء الله ان شاء الله ربي يبارك
يجعني يا كذا البنات الصغار الاولاد صغار
ونسا يعلم بهم ربي مجرحه ولات تحت الحيوط
مقول هو حرق ليها الفلوس لك انا نبغض
مسلمين معايا ربي هو
يعاوني والله ربي هو اللي يعاوني ربي
اعطيتهم لله سبحانه وتعالى وقدر على كل
مخلوق م غ ب ربي فهمت كيفش
وملها شي
ب عمره اخر قلت لك نط من فلسطين والله
عندي جمعه وانا فهمت
وخم